It's not something the royal family like to publicize,...
...but here's what we know about their main sources of income.
There's something called the Duchy of Lancaster,...
...almost 45,000 acres of commercial, agricultural,...
...and residential properties in England and Wales...
...owned on behalf of the Queen.
The Duchy comprises around 710 million dollars in net assets,...
...which is mostly held in trusts.
The profit made by these sites, castles, historical land,...
...and property at the heart of the capital...
...goes directly to the Queen and no other member of the Royal Family.
Last year, it netted her 20.7 million pounds or 26.7 million dollars.
Next up, there's the Duchy of Cornwall.
Like the Duchy of Lancaster, the Duchy of Cornwall is a private estate,...
...except this one is owned on behalf of Prince Charles.
In 2019, the Duchy of Cornwall paid Charles over 28 million dollars...
...on almost 1.2 billion dollars of net assets.
Though the profit goes directly to Charles,...
...both Prince William and Prince Harry receive money from the Duchy through their father.
Last year, they got around 5 million pounds in total from Prince Charles' fund.
The largest source of income for the Royals is government money...
...through a thing called the Sovereign Grant.
In the 1700s, the monarchy handed over revenues...
...from swathes of land to the government known as the Crown Estate.
Each year, the government pays a percentage of the profits...
...made on those assets back to the monarchy.
That annual income is known as the Sovereign Grant.
Last year, it amounted to almost 107 million dollars and it paid for royal duties...
...and the maintenance of palaces including Buckingham Palace.